[موسيقى]
من الافلام من كل ناحيه
لما حصلتنا الافيال ناس كتير مش متخيله ان
الفيل خطر لان في بعض الحيوانات بتشكل
خطوره اكتر من الاسود يعني يمكن الاسود ما
بتموتش الناس بعدد كبير زي بعض الحيوانات
التانيه زي الافيال زي فرس النهر زي
الحاجات دي الحيوانات دي حجمها ضخم جدا
وفعلا بتشكل خطوره حقيقيه على حياه البشر
فشعورنا كان ايه شعورنا كان بعض الناس مش
فاهمه ده وبعض الناس فاهمه ده منهم
السواق بتاع العربيه فبداوا يدونا تعليمات
خليكم في مكانكم خليكم حذرين ما حدش طلع
صوت ما حدش يمد ايده بره العربيه
احنا مبدئيا كنا داخلين بعربيه السفاري
وقفنا في مكان ما كان فيه بعض الافيال على
جانب الطريق ولقينا قائد القطيع بتاع
الافيال
ظهر من قدامنا وبدا يقرب من العربيه وبقيت
القطيع حوالينا يعني على يسار العربيه كان
فيه باقي القطيع وكان في كمان فيله صغيرين
فهما دايما بيحموا الفيلق الفعل الصغيرين
وكان في على اليمين فيلين كمان او فيل
كمان كان داخل علينا من الناحيه اليمين
فسواء العربيه وقف مكانه عشان ما يفهمش ان
فعلا ان احنا خطر عليهم فبدا الفيله تفهم
ده واحده واحده تدريجيا
انا عايز اقول لك مش عارف اللحظه دي هي مش
خوف بصراحه يعني انا الحمد لله عملت سفاري
كثير جدا في اماكن كثير جدا في العالم
واتحطيت في مواقف اصعب من مكانش خوف على
قد ما هو ان انا مركز اكتر هنتصرف ازاي
نركز مع الناس عشان محدش يعمل حاجه تضرنا
كلنا فده كان شعوري ان انا تنشن اكتر ان
انا
مشدود ان انا اعرف هنحل المشكله ازاي
[موسيقى]